former olympian caitlyn jenner is one of
the highest profile
challengers to governor gavin newsom in
california's upcoming
recall election jenner has been critical
of the state's
homeless crisis and of newsome's
response
to the coronavirus recent polls show
about half of california's registered
voters
plan to reject the recall and allow
newsome to finish his term
caitlyn jenner joins us now good morning
it's great to have you at the table it's
great to have people back at the table
it is my pleasure to be here thank you
for having me thank you for coming
yeah i've seen you in a while that is
very true but i have to say caitlyn it's
been a long time since we've had
somebody here
that doesn't work for viacom that's
right absolutely
you are not being paid by viacom cbs so
we're so glad you're at the table
okay another person you've said that um
california
needs a disrupter in your words a
compassionate disruptor yes
but you have never held elective office
why are you
ready to be governor
it was not an easy decision to make to
do this
it took a lot of time a lot of talking
to people but when i finally made the
decision and decided to get in i thought
i was very qualified why because i am an
outsider right now i have absolutely
no ties to sacramento um
and i think that's a good thing being
from the outside the insiders who we're
talking about is what makes you
qualified well these insiders are
qualified they're the ones responsible
for 13.3 percent
um uh tax rates uh we have the highest
tax
rates in the in the country um we have a
homeless
crisis in the cal in california they're
the ones responsible not me
i'm going in there to fix those things
but how do you feel caitlyn you can fix
it with no political experience
some would argue that now more than ever
you need somebody with a
political experience you've never held
what do you mean what do you mean by
political experience well who's had a
who's had a public office before
in 1973 when i moved to san jose i've
been
in california for 48 years 1973 when i
why did i when i went to san jose why
did i go there to train for the last
four years leading up to the games
because that's where the greatest
athletes of the world lived
i want to learn from them and i did and
i became the best
greatest athlete in the world i want to
do the same thing in sacramento
i want to surround myself would you say
all of these people with political
experience
okay eventually i would have to make the
final decisions on these things
so you're supposed to surround yourself
with a political team oh
an extraordinarily good i have met a lot
of these people already
i've talked to them as far as
tax issues on regulations
so smart they've been doing this for
years i would eventually have to make
the final decision
but i think i can attract those type of
people
into my administration caitlin the road
to the governor's mansion
goes through el barrio in california
latinx people are the largest
demographic group
in the state a huge voting bloc have you
engaged with the community to find out
what their priorities are for these
voters
i have engaged some at this point
obviously it's still new and i have a
lot to learn on that subject
but i've engaged with all voters i talk
every day to people i mean i go to the
gas station and i
you know i asked the guy getting on the
other side hey what did you know why are
you still here what are you what are the
problems with california
i constantly ask people and so yes
i mean but one in ten workers in
california are undocumented you said you
support a path
a pathway to citizenship for these
workers what would you do for them to
protect them
and and uh you know there's a there's a
a couple of
million at least a couple of million
estimated uh
people who have entered this country
illegally um
but they have been here for years i
think they should have
legal status in this country they're
great people
they've done wonderful work they are
part of our economy in california
they should be able to stay i would
provide protection of the people that
are here
they can stay legal status they've been
here for years
what i don't want is i don't want an
open border
where you have drug lords you know
terrorists bad people coming across
ms-13 bad people
we got to keep that out i don't want
criminals in this country i want good
people and you know what there's a lot
of great people a lot of my friends
are yes are you prepared for all the
incoming you're going to take and a lot
of eye rolls from people who are saying
is this just a photo op what is she
looking listen have you asked your
family to engage
you don't want them to engage in your
campaign as we all know
politics can be a pretty tough business
okay even in the family
yeah and unfortunately yes for anybody
and you know what i got pretty big
shoulders unfortunately but that's a
whole other story
yeah and i can take it people have come
after me all my life you know and i
i kind of just move on and do my own
thing but i did speak with all my
children i said hey i do not want one
tweet
i don't want you involved this is my
deal you tell them politics
you told them not to be involved yes not
to be involved whatsoever
i said if anybody asks any questions you
know in the media because they obviously
are in the media
i said just say no comment you know
address your comments to me
caitlyn there are buildings at least 20
states that are designed to limit access
to transgender health care and they're
being
pushed by republicans how do you feel
about that um
i would obviously not as governor be
follow that i would uh do you think your
party is wrong on this issue
uh yes i think the party's wrong a lot
that's why i'm running as an inclusive
candidate not just as as a repub
economically i'm running as a republican
lower taxes less regulations a
pro-business environment i was talking
with the head of
some of these major companies they all
left they left because it's not a
friendly business environment i want to
make a friendly business buyer
but um socially i am
much more inclusive than i would think
the normal republican would be and
that's the way i would treat that bottom
line is you are running for governor you
are serious you want this job
i want this job baby i'm going to change
this state
you know you can't have a healthy
america with a sick california
and right now california is pretty sick
all right caitlyn jenner thank you so
much for joining us this morning we do
appreciate it